c'était sa deuxième maison
pendant près de dix ans l'entraîneur des
saguenéens de chicoutimi était chez lui
ici
son nombre est toujours bien présente au
dessus de la patinoire
c'est certain qu'à chaque fois que
julien ça me fait drôle parce que j'ai
passé une bonne partie de ma vie ici
donnée dans des arénas
il a quitté l'équipe en 2011 mais son
record de victoires dans la ligue de
hockey junior majeur du québec n'a
toujours pas été battu le temps
l'entraîneur devenu politicien n'est
plus aussi à l'aise si je pense que j'ai
fait mon temps au hockey je suis arrivé
dans un moment où la culture est
différente d'aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui c'est la place aux jeunes
alors procédé de sages à ce moment là
l'euro qui tolérait que les instructeurs
deviennent des vedettes derrière leur
banc qui montaient sur les bateaux qui
assaillent aujourd'hui c'est ea on
accepte nous sommes fils desgagnés
ancien arbitre de la ligue junior majeur
a vu richard martel évolué comme joueur
puis comme entraîneur pendant plus de
vingt ans des années où j'ai arbitré
puis richard est instructeur le match de
hockey avec 7 8 10 12 bataille terrible
[Applaudissements]
avec le temps de chauffe c'est à 10 il
s'est adapté également parce que on
voulait plus que les instructeurs de
bienne ce genre d'individu des données
peut-être le mauvais exemple
cette façon que j'ai adoré quand je lis
connu pigeon ce qu'on se parle encore
aujourd'hui
charles hudon aujourd'hui joueur de
hockey professionnel avait 16 ans quand
il a commencé à jouer au richard martel
[Musique]
une personne qui va toujours répond on
au négatif
toutes les choses qui sont contre moi
puis lui il savait payement parler des
fois qu'il allait être dur envers moi
mais c'est comment j'allais réagir ils
voient qu'ils allaient me faire grandir
sa grille
du meilleur potentiel a passé près
garder là quelques chantiers mais
certains joueurs que ça leur briquet que
salah arrêté je pense que ma première
année ça a été difficile pour certains
cas quichotte à tomber sur leur dos il
naquit régis est moins bien toi qui les
sous tend désormais le nom de richard
martel est encore présent dans les
émissions de sport gens martèle patrick
roy du moins à sa gle et wiltord
dirigeants martin est un showman
derrière le banc de son équipe de hockey
passionné
argh envers les arbitres une fois piqué
une crise avec ses joies mais j'entends
changeront pas le personnage
commissionnée
c'est sa popularité en tant
qu'entraîneur explosifs qu'il a mené en
politique d'abord élu haut la main dans
une élection partielle en 2018
il a été réélu plus difficilement aux
élections générales de 2010 9
il connaît ses dossiers j'aime richard
c'est mon coach farid eau qui est pour
notre caucus un an plus tard il retrouve
rôle de chef d'equipe en tant que
lieutenant des conservateurs au québec
j'étais seul à l'appuyer puis un
travaillant avec on a développé une
bonne relation de gros mandat c'est un
gros mandat mais moi j'ai un coach qui
aime les défis
ces quincailleries challenge je me sens
je vis de ça puis bâtir des équipes
ça fait partie de mon adn tout en
exigeant surtout le bouillant entraîneur
de rock qui se retrouve au centre de la
stratégie électorale des conservateurs
le nouveau chef compte sur lui pour
gagner des sièges au québec et l'aider à
former le prochain gouvernement
je pense qu'il devrait être plus
prudents au niveau de ses réponses
là mon livre amour est un look beaucoup
de charisme quand l'un dans le même port
icône une jarre martel dans ma vie
souvent beaucoup de gens ont dit prends
pas ça pas l'expérience à chaque fois
quelqu'un disait prends pas ça tape à
l'expérience je la prenais puis je ris
alors on va regarder c'était défilant où
ça va nous mener
richard martel doit maintenant éviter
les punitions les expulsions ou même le
congédiement comme cela lui est arrivé
dans le passé